[Música]
no pongan en peligro el futuro de
nuestros hijos activistas antinucleares
se manifestaron frente al parlamento
japonés rechazan el plan del gobierno de
verter el agua contaminada de la central
nuclear de fukushima al océano pacífico
diez años después del tsunami que
provocó el desastre las reacciones en
cadenas siguen afectando a los reactores
dañados y el complejo casi no tiene
espacio para almacenar el agua de
refrigeración que se acumula a un ritmo
de 170 toneladas diarias el agua
contaminada se filtra primero antes de
ser almacenada pero el dispositivo no
tiene la capacidad de eliminar el tritio
un isótopo radiactivo del hidrógeno
a nivel de tritio por debajo de los
límites impuestos por las autoridades
japonesas y también por la ong en cuanto
a las normas de seguridad del agua
potable los científicos consideran que
niveles bajos de trillón no son
peligrosos para el medio ambiente pero
los pescadores japoneses están
preocupados
elefantes de alto
y hemos dicho repetidamente al gobierno
que nos oponemos categóricamente a este
plan de muestra de texto los habitantes
temen en efecto las repercusiones del
vertido sobre la calidad de la industria
pesquera un sector esencial en una
región ya castigada y aunque el proceso
no es nuevo las aguas residuales que
contienen tritio se vierten regularmente
en los océanos china y corea del sur
también se muestran preocupadas por la
decisión de tokio más de un millón de
toneladas de agua de refrigeración están
almacenadas actualmente en el sitio de
fukushima su liberación en el océano
podría comenzar dentro de dos años